los daños causados por las inundaciones
de estos últimos días en Italia son
enormes el gobernador de la región
Emilia romaña habla de varios billones
de euros me encuentro en este momento en
checena uno de los municipios más
afectados por el desastre aquí el
trabajo de limpieza será Monumental hoy
pude seguir a un equipo de bomberos que
ayudó a una familia que quedó atrapada
en una zona inaccesible vi la
destrucción por todos lados en varios
pueblos los centros todavía inundados
negocios invadidos por el barro y en las
zonas Rurales la situación también es
crítica miles de hectáreas de cultivos
han quedado totalmente destruidos el
ministro del medio ambiente ha anunciado
que el estado de calamidad natural será
declarado para todas las zonas golpeadas
por estas inundaciones y el gobierno
está preparando un paquete de ayudas
financieras para los habitantes muchos
de ellos están todavía profundamente
consternados chocados por el trauma que
han vivido y muy preocupados Ya que en
las próximas horas se prevé el retorno
de las lluvias aquí en el norte de
Italia